[Music]
hi welcome to our talk drawn out how
Android renders the UI it was almost
called something else we called it this
and then somebody in some administration
position decided it was actually going
to be called how to optimize your app
for top rendering performance or
something that wasn't what the talk was
about so fortunately we changed back
instead since we're gonna tell you the
details of how actually stuff works I'm
Chet Haase I'm from the Android toolkit
team and then little Mikey I'm on the
inter-atomic team and I do real-time
graphics and that's kind of what we're
talking about today so we have given
versions of this talk before and we
thought we were done and then we
realized that enough stuff has changed
inside the system that maybe it was time
to go through this again and see where
we're at so this is our attempt to do
that let's go so first of all there's
this word wondering what do we mean by
that normally it means melting fat in
order to clarify it it's not quite what
we're gonna talk about today instead
we're talking about the process of
actually turning all that stuff like
buttons and checkboxes and everything on
the screen into pixels that the user can
look at and there's a lot of things
going on there's a lot of details that
we aren't glossing over today because we
only have 40 minutes to do this but
we'll dump a lot of details on you along
the way so first of all I'm going to
take you through there's gonna be a
bunch of colored dots on the top and
these will be sort of a visual cue for a
lot of the rest of the talk so I'm gonna
walk through sort of the life of what
happens in the flow of information down
to the pixels on the screen really
quickly we have this thing called the
choreographer and that kicks in usually
60 times a second and it says hey vsync
this is the interval at which the frame
is being synced buffers flip onto the
screen it's a good time for us to
process a lot of information and then
handle rendering that information as a
result of that so we get a vsync
operation that's sent up to the Java SDK
Lan's and we're on the UI thread and all
of a sudden we need to process input
events which can trigger changes in
properties we also run any animations so
we change property values again that may
trigger things like layouts and
invalidation we do then the whole
traversal path which is measuring views
to figure out how large they are laying
them out which is actually positioning
them to where they need to be and then
drawing them once all of that
information is done we sync the result
of that information over to this thing
called the render thread and the render
thread takes that and says okay well I'm
going to then execute these I'm going to
basically turn these into native
versions of all that information we
produce at the Java layer and then I'm
going to get a buffer from the GPU so
that I have a place to write this
information and then I'm going to
actually issue all these GPU commands as
OpenGL stuff over there and then I'm
gonna say okay it's time to swap the
buffer and then I turn it over the GPU
and then the graphic system does
something called compositing and we're
gonna talk about most of these steps
today so compositing is I think
something we've never explained before
so we're gonna go in a little bit of
details but it's part of the end or the
rendering a picture so the little
colored dots on the top of the screen
will be sort of noting where we are in
the process as we work through a few
examples so that we can understand this
better
speaking of examples here's a simple one
so let's suppose that we have a user and
the user clicks on an item I wrote this
awesome recycler view application that
looks exactly like this I know it is
because that's a screenshot from my
awesome application it's a recycler view
with a bunch of items in it and when the
user clicks on when this amazing thing
happens it turns into a random color on
background it's incredible I could give
you the source but I don't know it's
pretty complicated I'm not sure you'd
understand it so here's the amazing
layout for my amazing demo application
there's a constraint layout there's a
recycler view inside of it and then I
populated it runtime with a bunch of
random items in there
all right the view hierarchy for this
thing looks basically like this in fact
it doesn't look basically like this it
looks exactly like this so you walk down
from the decor of you and you've got it
linear layout and frame layout
actually you sure why but we have the
deep nesting there but whatever history
we have a bunch of stuff for action bar
in there none of that really matters
what we're concerned about here is
what's actually going on in the content
hierarchy because that's what you can
affect with your application so we have
content frame layout we have the
constraint layout on the outside
wrapping the recyclerview
and then all of the items specifically
these are the items that are on screen
because those are the only ones that are
actually being measured and laid out and
drawn alright so what happens we will
walk through this example and walk
through that entire flow that we went
through at the beginning so user clicks
there's a vsync operation that gets sent
up and we process input during the input
phase and we notice that this is a click
I'm glossing over some details here
actually we're gonna notice first that
there was it down and then there was an
up and then I guess processes to click
just take it for granted we're
eventually going to process it click
here alright that ends up in this item
clicked method that I haven't may amaze
Allah complex example and in there we're
going to set the background color on
this item to a random color that's why I
call the method random all right that
gets sent over to the set background
color in view Java which does a bunch of
stuff to set the color on the background
drawable and then eventually calls this
method called invalidate invalidation is
the process it doesn't actually redraw
the views it's the process of telling
the view hierarchy that something needs
to be redrawn so you get a click that
happens on the item down at the bottom
so that item to you see it's surrounded
by green we have a little invalidate
method that gets called on that and that
basically walks up the tree it calls a
series of methods all the way up to
treat because the view needs knows that
it needs to be redrawn but it actually
needs to propagate that information all
the way up the hierarchy so that then we
can redraw all the things on the way
down later
so we call invalid a child all the way
up the hierarchy that eventually ends up
in a massive class that we have called
view route in pull Java and we have this
invalidate child method there and that
basically does nothing except says okay
I need to schedule a traversal which
means
okay I've taken information that
somebody got invalidated somewhere that
means that I need to run my traversal
code later at the end of this process
traversal is the process of doing all
the phases that are necessary for
actually rendering that frame
specifically it does measure how big the
views are layout setting the views
position and size and drawing the views
all of that is called traversal so we've
scheduled a traversal that's going to
happen at some later time and that later
time is now so in the same frame we end
up in the traversal code in this perform
traversals method it's going to do a
perform trah which ends up calling a
draw method onto core view and basically
that's going to propagate all the way
down so the draw method actually ends up
in an optimization that we implemented
back in Monaco called get display list
so a display list is a structure that
stores the rendering information right
so if you look at the way the button
code is written or you know view code in
general we call graphics commands in
canvas like I don't know draw
backgrounds draw drawable draw a line
whatever but these end up as operations
in a display list this is a compact way
of representing those operations as well
as the parameters to the option up to
operations so we call get display list
the decor of you did not change in fact
so it's going to say well I didn't
change but I can certainly get the
display was for my child and then on all
the way down the tree until he gets to
item two and it says oh I did change
like when invalidate was called on me
that triggered something so that I know
I need to redraw myself so get display
list actually ends up being a draw call
on the view where it regenerates its own
display list so now it so ends up in the
salon draw method that ends up in the
operations in the display was for that
display was consists of you know for
this item basically rect information and
text information pretty basic and then
we have the display list for basically
the entire hierarchy right so it wasn't
just the view itself but we have the
view hierarchy itself is reproduced in
this hierarchy of display lists all the
way down
so now we have to display was for the
entire tree and that's all that we need
to do on the UI thread now we need to
sync that information over to the render
thread and the render thread is a
separate thread that's actually dealing
with the GPU side of this operation on
the Java site we produced all the
information on the native side then we
actually produce we take that
information then sync it over to the GPU
so we have the sync operation where
basically we copy a handle over there
and we also copy some related
information we copy the damaged area
because it's important to know that that
item - that's the only thing that
changed during that frame which means we
don't need to redraw anything else
outside of that area so we're gonna copy
over the clip bounds there so that we
know what needs to be redrawn and we're
also going to do some optimization stuff
like uploading bitmaps so this is a good
time to do it at the beginning of the
frame give them some time to actually
turn those into textures along the way
while we're doing the other stuff it
mentions here that we're uploading the
known hardware bitmaps so how are
bitmaps is a new type of bitmap
configuration that was added in Android
Oh
so typically when you have a bitmap we
have to allocate the memory on the Java
side and then when it comes time to draw
we have to make a copy of the bitmap on
the GPU this is expensive in text time
it doubles the amount of RAM we are
using so using the hardware bitmaps that
are available in Oreo you can skip the
Java side of the equation and you can
have a bitmap that leaves only on the
GPUs which we're not going to modify
this bitmap ever again this is a really
efficient way memory wise to store your
bitmaps memory we have mentioned the
render thread before this is something
that we introduced in the lollipop
release it is a separate thread that
only talks to the GPU it's native code
there's no call-out so after Java code
there's certainly no call-outs out to
application code it just talks to the
GPU we did this so we still need to do
basically the same thing we did pre
render thread which is we produce all
the display list information and then we
sink or we send that display list
information to the GPU so it's sort of
serial but the render thread is able to
do things atomically like the circular
reveal animations as well as the ripple
animations as well as vector drawable
animations can happen atomically on the
render thread so that's something that
can happen without stalling the UI
thread and in the
I'm the UI thread can be doing other
things while it's idle after it's synced
like maybe some of the the idle prefetch
worked for recyclerview that was done
last year so render thread kicks in
we've synced everything we have the
display list we have the damage area and
then we do we turn the display list into
something that we call DL ops display
list operations so you can see that we
have that fill operation in the middle
that's the thing that we turn green
there and then we have some
optimizations that we perform so we have
largest optimizations we we do here so
for instance if you do alpha rendering
by calling set alpha on the view or if
you set a hardware layer on the view we
try to identify the drawing commands
that that need to be targeted to those
layers and we move them as at the
beginning of the frame these votes do
state changes inside the GPU which are
extremely expensive so without doing
this kind of optimization you would see
like horrible horrible performance and
it's not that because the GPU itself
will be slow that if you would just give
waiting for the CPU to give its
instructions the other one we're doing
and we're going to show you an actual
practical example
let's go reordering and batching we look
at all those operations and you can see
in this example because we have list
items we ensure leave a lot of
operations that are similar so we're
going to draw a rectangle then we're
gonna go draw text and we're gonna draw
a rectangle and text again and again
here we're changing the state of the GPU
several times but instead what we can do
is if the comments don't overlap we can
draw all the rectangles together then we
can draw all the text together so this
is part of the reordering and batching
and sometimes what we do we say look if
we see no a bunch of tags that use the
same color in the same font they don't
have to be different draw text calls
they can be just a single one that
covers the entire screen you can see
here the original TL wops has a fill
operation and then it wanted to draw
some text which is going to be end up
being texture map copies from the glyph
cache then it's got a fill operation and
then some more text and a fill and so
we've got all these operations
interleaved so after the reordering
operation then it looks a little more
like this we've got a series of fills
and a series of text operations they can
even be batched together to be more
optimal which we will see here so this
is an example of Gmail's that was in the
honey
era you can see how here we modified the
pipeline to slow down the rendering and
you can see exactly how Gmail was
drawing so we have a lot of list item
and we just draw them in the exact order
that they are they exist in if you hark
in the order of your code actually
they're called the drop calls that you
make on the canvas or respect that order
unfortunately like I said it's very
inefficient so instead after batching
and merging and reordering
we get this you can see in particular
that all the stars were drawn at the
same time and most of the texts occur
all at once what's interesting is we we
are drawing all the list item
backgrounds one after the other so
that's good the reordering worked the
batching didn't work and it's partly
because the list items are slightly
overlapping so when comments overlap we
have to draw them one after the other to
honor the blending to make sure the
Alpha values are correct and so the
effect really depends on the application
if I remember correctly in KitKat the
settings application was we could draw
the whole screen in about six draw calls
instead of dozens and dozens as invested
by the view heart
so this is a very important optimization
for us I think this work at the time on
current devices saves something like a
millisecond which doesn't sound like
much unless you realized that we have to
do everything within 16 so it was
actually a huge improvement that allowed
Gmail to be less janky because then it
wasn't pushed out into the next frame as
often all right so back to our
explanation of everything then we have
the clip reject so this is where we feed
in the information about the damage area
right so we know where item two was on
the screen and we know that we don't
need to draw anything outside of that
so as we're processing these DL opps we
know that we can basically throw away
anything that is drawing outside of that
area and graphics that's called a
trivial reject so we trivially reject
all the deal opps that weren't
intersecting with that area and now all
we have to do is draw a fill and some
text and a line so we do that in the
process of doing that we do a get buffer
this is usually an implicit operation we
don't request a buffer it's more that as
soon as we start doing GPU operations
then the GPU hands us the buffer more
particularly surface flinger hands us
the buffer that we can then put these
commands into
then we issue the commands this is a
series of GL commands as you can see on
the slide it says JL commands basically
the equivalent of what we need for
whatever doing the fill where the text
bitmap copies lines whatever and then we
swap the buffers so this is us saying we
are done with all of our rendering
operations we're ready to display this
frame on the screen it's a request to
surface flinger to then swap the buffer
basically we're done drawing to the
buffer you can swap this with the one
that's in front and it'll put it on the
screen meanwhile in surface flinger then
we have the composite step which Ramon
is gonna talk a lot about later but
basically it takes all of the windows on
the screen we see here the navigation
bar the status bar and the actual
content window for our application it
combines all of those in the hardware
compositor puts them on screen and then
tada we're done alright so that was a
really simple example let's look at a
super complicated example this one's
gonna be in two phases one so we're
gonna drag the list up so we're gonna
drag it and then as we drag it we're
going to move the items a little bit and
then eventually if we keep moving them
we're gonna have a new item appeared so
we're gonna look at two versions of this
there's the move only version so as we
drag it up a new item not a new item
appears everything just shifts a little
bit up so first of all we need to
process the down so we have a vsync it
says time to process input events so we
do that and we end up in code like this
on touch event in recycler view it says
well there was a down operation and all
it needs to do is register where that
down happened it doesn't need to process
anything nothing changed on the screen
we just registered that the user
actually pressed down so we record that
for later and there's no op we don't do
any of the rest of the stuff we talked
about because nothing changed all right
they keep dragging then we end up in
similar code so we process input on the
next frame and we say okay on touch
event oh now we know that they've
actually moved when we know how much
they move because we saved the old X&Y
and we calculate the Delta and now we
call this thing called offset top and
bottom we basically for all the views on
the screen we simply move them in Y and
offset top and bottom call something
it's an invalidation method
but it's slightly different it says
invalidate view property this is an
optimization that we put in in probably
honeycomb second release or something
with displaylist properties so when I
talked about this playlist earlier there
was one nuance that I left out we have
the information about the operations and
the parameters for the graphics
operations but we also have the
information about some core displaylist
properties which are basically
properties of the view like the
translation property rotation alpha and
these are properties which we don't need
to re-render the view to change we can
simply change them in the display with
structure itself and then they get
picked up at GPU issue time so it's a
very fast operation for us to do that so
instead of invalidating a view and
redrawing everything in that view all we
do is say change the translation
property in this view so the way that
happens is we call invalidate view
property that propagates all the way up
the tree because we still need to know
at the top layer what happens but it's a
much more optimal step so this ends up
in schedule traversals as it did before
in the draw it ends up in perform
traversals but perform draw can do a
much simpler version of this because the
display was didn't actually change all
we did was change display was properties
inside of it so we can immediately sync
that information over to the renter
thread we can then execute that turn
that into display list ops
get the buffer basically everything is
as before all right let's go through the
second phase of that super complicated
example user keeps dragging and as they
drag a new item appears on the bottom
sophie sink we process the input we end
up in and method something like this
okay we know that they've moved oh but
that means that we need to trigger the
creation and the bind of that new item
there that ends up in code like this
where we actually add a view to the
parent so the recycler view is going to
get a new view and it's going to call
request layout so request layout is kind
of like invalidation but instead of
saying I need to be redrawn it says I
need to be remarried and relayed out and
that could side effect everybody there
so we basically propagate or request
layout all the way up the tree like
invalidation and then we do measure and
layout on the entire tree just to see
what change there so request layout
happens on the parent and then that
propagates all the way up
and that ends up again in schedule
traversals our friend and then perform
traversals we're not talking about the
draw stuff now we're gonna do a perform
measure and a perform layout measure is
basically asking all of the views how
big they would like to be it's a request
and then layout says this is how big
you're going to be and this is where
you're going to be positioned it's a
negotiation between the views and all of
their parents according to all the
constraints in the system so we do a
perform measure that basically calls
measure at the top and that propagates
all the way down and then we have all
the information about how big all the
views want to be and that is good enough
for us to calculate the layout
information then we propagate layout all
the way down the tree and once that
happens on the item and the parent that
changed then we actually layout that
item and we're ready to go now we can
actually draw things and everything is
as before so the nuance here was just
the layout side except an important
nuance is we're talking about all of
this request layout and measure and
layout happening for this recyclerview
situation however rick recyclerview
optimizes this it knows enough about its
own parent and its children that it
actually can just offset the views
instead of doing the request layout it
can actually just move the views out of
the way and create the new item so
optimization for a recycler view as well
as the older ListView alright so now
we're going to talk about how surface
flinger our window composites or
composites all the windows on the screen
this is interesting
well first of all because it's always
interesting to learn something new about
technology but also because you will
understand some concepts that are behind
some of the public API is like surface
surface texture surface view or in the
media the media codec so before we can
understand composition we have to
understand a very important concept on
Android called the buffer queue so the
buffer queue as the name suggests it's
just a queue of buffers they're where
our graphics buffers live
typically we're gonna have one two three
buffers there are different options
internally where when we set up a buffer
queue we can request how many buffers
wants and and very importantly a buffer
queue has two endpoints we have the
producer and we have the consumer so
typically the way we use a buffer queue
the producer calls a method called DQ
buffer on the queue it grabs a buffer
from the queue now it owns it it can do
any kind of rendering it can be sending
the pixel data directly can be using
OpenGL it can be using canvas it doesn't
really matter and and when use OpenGL
this is basically what happens when you
call swap buffers at the end that's when
we're producing the content inside the
buffer so when the producer is done
producing the content it calls Q buffer
and gives the buffer back to the to the
perfect shoe now consumer can grab the
next buffer in the queue using acquire
so in calls acquire buffer it takes the
first available but for in the queue it
does whatever it has to do with it and
when it's done it puts it back by
calling release so it's a pretty simple
concept of course if you were to look at
the code you know all the header files
and all the knife code involved it's
pretty complicated in part because the
two end points of a perfect you can live
in different processes and this is
exactly what happens this is how our
surface compositor works so when you
create a window in the system you have
the window manager and you have surface
fingers we the window manager is
effectively the producer in the scenario
and surface flinger is our consumer so
when you call window manager that ad
view and this is what's done
automatically for you when you create a
dialog when you create a toast I believe
when you create an activity instantly we
create a window object that window
object has a sibling on the surface
flinger upside called a layer the names
can be a little confusing because in
graphics we have to deal with buffers
and queues and that's all we do and we
quickly run out of names and the
graphics team I thought of so that's
what we have surface and surface
textures and buffer queue and layer and
window and yeah so it's a little bit
messy so we have a layer surface flinger
it's basically a window and the layer is
the components in the system that
creates an own the buffer queue for your
application so it creates a buffer queue
and we have a way to send and
to your application by creating a
surface so whatever you see a surface in
one of our API is you really have the
producer endpoint of a perfect cube that
lives somewhere else in the system
either in your process or in some other
process most of the time it's gonna be
inside surface flinger so now when the
typical use case for you as an
application the application developer
you're gonna see you're going to deal
with the surface API when you create a
surface you so the worst of SEO works is
your window as its own surface that we
see here then we cut a hole through that
surface effectively and we ask the
window manager an surface flinger to
create a second surface and we just
slide it underneath and we pretend that
they're part of the same window but they
are not they have two different there
are two different surfaces they have two
different buffer queues and they can be
completely independent from one another
so if user surface view your polygons I
use a OpenGL or volcano or a media
player to generate content so for
instance in this case we have OpenGL yes
it's gonna acquire a DQ a buffer it's
gonna do some rendering it's gonna Cuba
the buffer back into the surface and
therefore into the surface the buffer
queue if you use a surface texture so
your producer you saw your consumer will
be OpenGL so you create a surface
texture by giving me the texture ID in
that case the surface texture creates
and owns the buffer queue so that will
often be in your own process then you
have to pass that surface texture to
some producer and to do this you create
the endpoints yourself by creating by
creating a surface there's a constructor
of surface that takes a surface texture
so you create your surface you send it
to some other application and then when
your OpenGL code is ready to render it
goes acquire to get a buffer from the
from the buffer queue it does its
rendering it's gonna itself produce a
buffer inside another queue and then
when it's done it can call release text
review is the widget that's part of a UI
tolki that you can use to benefit from
surface surface texture in that patio in
case the render thread that we talked
about is the consumer of the surface
texture and you're still responsible for
are getting the surface from the texture
of you and giving it to a producer of
your choosing you can think of it as a
fancy image you effectively its own
image you that you can update really
efficiently using a hardware
acceleration in recent years we we used
to tell you that six of you why is the
solution instead of surface you when you
want it to integrate you know a video or
OpenGL rendering inside the complex
application for instance if you had a
list view or count view or anything that
was animated surface view because it's
made of two different windows was not
really efficient for that and it was not
synchronized with the rendering of your
own application this has been fixed in
the recent versions of Android so most
of the time on recent versions of
Android you should use a surface view
instead of a texture view user text
review only when you have to maybe send
which between other views or use an
animation that's not supported by the
surface I think that was the Oh release
there was oh maybe and maybe what are
the two you have to test I would say
reason so and here's a list of different
producers and consumers in the platform
so we looked at surface view and surface
texture OpenGL ES is a producer it can
also be a consumer so remember when Chet
waste art was saying that that lifecycle
of a frame at some point we'd get a
buffer that's when we called DQ buffer
from the render thread and this is done
typically when we do the first draw call
and at the end when we call it just a
buffer to tell the driver that were done
with our frame it will actually produce
their frame and put it back in the
buffer queue you can also use things
like Vulcan the media player and media
codec and we have many many more
throughout the platform now the actual
composition so we have created multiple
windows that each have their own layer
surface flinger knows about all those
layers and to talk to the display
surface figure actually talks to
something called a hardware competitor
the holo composer hardware composer is a
hardware abstraction layer that we use
because we want to avoid using the GPU
and we need to compose it all those
windows on screen one of the reason is
to save battery it's more power
efficient that way it's also to make
sure that your application has access to
basically all the capabilities of the
GPU we don't take it away from you and
in the best you may have heard that that
you need
number view windows you put on screen
and you'll see why in a few slides
so we have the holo composer it's
effectivity of block of hardware that
that's really fast and taking multiple
bitmaps and compositing them together on
screen we just talked about this so the
way it actually works the hover composer
is really a kind of a protocol here I'm
gonna describe the older hardware
composer it's called hot octopus r10
moist confuse now we use one called the
ha composer - but it's much more
complicated so I'm not gonna describe it
here but it basically works the same way
so stuff is sitting here has a bunch of
layers and we're gonna call prepare on
this on the hop composer and we're gonna
send all the layers to the hardrock
composer and ask it to tell us what he
wants to do with every layer every hard
rock composer is the proprietary piece
of hardware in you know the phone or
tablet you're using and there is no way
that we can write the drivers for all
the different other composers out there
so instead the professor's gonna tell us
what he wants to do so in this case we
have a layer the heart composer replies
overlay that means you have our composer
understands the pixel format of that
window and tells us that it can handle
it and it's gonna do the composition for
that window so we keep going it's
telling us overlay for the second layer
it's telling us overlays for the third
layer so that's great that means all the
composition can be done automatically
for us on our behalf in a very efficient
way so now all our layers are matched to
overlays we call set we send all the
layers to the hardrock composer this
time for actual composition and the hot
dog composer sends everything to the
screen now a more complex example so we
have a number of layers we call prepare
for the first one everything goes fine
the whole composer says overlay can
handle it but for some reason for the
next one it says frame buffer so that
can happen when you're using a pixel
format that's not supported it could be
because you're using a rotation and
occupational doesn't know how to handle
rotation or we have too many layers on
the screen or any number of reasons that
are specific to that type of composer
this was much more common in devices
probably a three or four or a long right
used to have about four Hardware layers
that you could use that's four that's
five
so we here used to have four and on
pixel two without going into too much
detail you have basically seven so it's
much better than it used to be but if
you have a pixel through Excel we use
two of those layers to draw the rounded
corners so you don't really have seven
you have five it's actually more six
because they can be merged by the
composer anyway lots of details it can
be really complicated you don't need to
know about all those details anyway in
this case we have one year that can go
directly to the hardrock composer but we
have two layers that have been marked
frame buffer so and that's what the hard
part starts for us because when we have
layers that are not handled by the
hardrock composer we need to use the GPU
to composite them ourselves
so surface flinger has to be able to do
everything that the hardware can do and
in that situation we need to create
basically a scratch buffer another layer
in the format that we know the hardware
composer can accept and then we use
custom OpenGL code to do the composition
ourselves of those two layers so then
once we're done with that part were left
with only two layers and we know that
those can be send it to the other
composers so that's what we do we call
set and then they show up on screen so
if you if you're curious sometime you
can run this command adb shell dumps
this surface flinger and circuit is
capital F okay very important and it'll
spit out way way way more information
than you want but one of the things that
it's going to show you is a table of the
windows on the screen and whether they
are currently represented as overlays or
frame buffer although you have to run
this command pretty quickly because
there are tons of optimizations in
slowly so what can happen sometimes is
if layers have been on screen for a
while and we know they are not changing
the octopus room might be collapsing
them into a single layer until they
change again so the output of that
command is sometime a little bit
misleading because you might be seeing
the result of optimizations based on
time so the best thing to do is use each
one this when you're running an
animation or something is changing on
screen that's going to be the most
variable information for you so a few
other things that we haven't talked
about we used to tell you to use the
variant of that
detector detects a rectangle so you
could vary that only part of your view
that you knew needed to be repainted
that was particularly important with
older Android devices because bandwidth
was extremely limited we are using
software rendering and even in the early
days of GPU rendering for us we were
pretty much pretty easily maxing out the
GPU so those were really important
savings you don't need to do this
anymore
and even on recent versions of Android
before this was deprecated it was
actually ignored by the system now what
happens every time you call in validate
or invalidate with a rectangle on a view
the render thread is going to re-render
that of you or we computed so damaged
area you don't have to worry about it
and one of the reasons we're getting rid
of it is not only is it not that
necessary anymore for savings it's also
because it's error prone it's real easy
to have enough buy one error or rounding
error and to get artifacts on screen and
certain I can attest that because we
fixed so many bugs linked to this to the
use of those aps and the framework
itself I still has bugs I believe around
that so now we don't have to worry about
it
recyclerview is now able to do
prefetching of item ahead of time yeah
we mentioned this earlier this is one of
the wins that we're now getting out of
having a separate render thread because
now well there's idle time the UI thread
was done with its work after it's inked
we can use that idle time productively
for doing other things like fetching
things that it know it might need in the
next few frames for composition
internally we have a concept of virtual
display design API you can use for
instance that's what we use when we take
a screenshot or when we record a video
or when we do casting Chrome casting for
instance what we effectively doing is
asking so first finger to perform a
composition but not to display directly
just into another surface so it's
another way of producing a surface if
you're interested there's a next silent
a simple application called grafica with
a k' available on github it was written
by a member of the graphics team a few
years ago it's basically a collection of
old
you can do with surface flinger with
surfaces with surface view with the
media encoder with virtual displays it's
a very interesting piece of code to look
at color transform so in in Android all
we introduce color management and that's
one of the core transforms we can apply
things like nightlight are also color
transforms we also have color blindness
simulation those can be handled by the
hardware composer in specific situations
and they can either cause for for
performance issues for instance a while
back
nightlight was not supported I believe
on the n5 x or the n6p one of the
reasons was the hardware we didn't add
the drivers that could do the color
transform so we had to fall back to g3
composition it was really expensive it
was hurting the battery so we didn't
have the feature on the device and
lecture said there are many many more
details that our rendering pipeline this
was just a very high level overview we
gave a number of talks in the past that
gives explaining more details what we do
for instance in the UI Runner itself how
we do the batching and emerging that
kind of optimization so if you're
interested you can research at our
calculation is interesting I think we
had a talk where we talked about some of
those details but exactly where does
that fit the rendering pipeline is sort
of clever but yes lots more going on
there but hopefully this gives you a
general sense of how things work on
Android and that's cool done so we'll
stop it there thank you
you
[Music]